we just saw with Caroline that looking
at the differences between two files is
a little bit annoying to do manually and
that there are tools that make it easy
to do automatically think for a bit
about how this could help with the
process producing good code throughout
the course will ask you to take a minute
to think about things and write down
your thoughts about material we've just
covered I know it can be tempting to say
oh I don't need to do this or I'll just
wait to see what you guys have to say
about it but doing these exercises will
really help cement the concepts as we go
seriously there's research on this check
the instructor notes for details also
later in the course you'll be getting
practice using version control by saving
different versions of these files since
this course isn't about writing code
this will be one of the primary sources
of practice you'll get so be sure to
actually write something down each time
you see one of these prompts so that you
have some content to work with don't
worry about pausing this video while you
get things set up or to see the
reflection prompt you'll see some
directions after this video ends will
ask you to create a separate file for
each lessons reflections you'll also
want to make sure to use a simple text
editor like sublime notepad plus plus
Emacs or vim and not a rich text editor
like Microsoft Word or OpenOffice and
use plain text txt files so that you can
easily look at their content on the
command line please do take the time to
do this right now